und was hat jetzt aufgerufen den
nächsten tagesordnungspunkt und der
andere sich tatsächlich darum dass die
flutkatastrophe im aartal schon ein jahr
her ist am 15 juli genauer gesagt im
jahr 20 21 kamen die großen regenfälle
135 menschen starben damals
766 wurden verletzt von der
naturkatastrophe
in besonderer weise betroffen waren
95.000 menschen 42.000 besonders stark
im vergünstigten aartal und darüber
diskutiert jetzt der deutsche bundestag
zunächst die innenministerin nennt sie
so viel regen fiel an manchen orten in
rheinland pfalz und nordrhein westfalen
an nur an einem einzigen tag aus dem
extremen starkregen wurde
unvorstellbare
sturzfluten und massive überschwemmungen
die fluten rissen alles mit sich häuser
brücken
strassen schulen rathaus kirchen und
auch menschen
fast ein jahr ist es her dass wir eine
der schlimmsten naturkatastrophen in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland erlebt haben
183 menschen verloren ihr leben mehr als
800 menschen wurden zum teil
schwerstverletzt und meine damen und
herren ich denke es ist angemessen in
dieser debatte an die opfer zu gedenken
und vor allen dingen an die angehörigen
wenn ich hier und heute darüber berichte
habe ich immer noch die bilder der
zerstörung vor augen und es macht mich
immer noch fassungslos und sehr
betroffen aus dem ganzen land kamen
freiwillige in die überfluteten regionen
mein großer tief empfundener dann gilt
all jenen die bis zur erschöpfung dort
geholfen haben sehr selbstlos die
menschen unterstützen
und unser gemeinsamer dank gilt
natürlich den einsatzkräften der
feuerwehr der polizei der bundeswehr dem
technischen hilfswerk der
hilfsorganisation wie der lädiertes
kreuz johanniter malteser und auch den
vielen freiwilligen den menschen den
nachbarn den freunden den familien
lassen sie mich an dieser stelle im
namen der bundesregierung all diesen
helferinnen und helfern noch mal
ausdrücklich für ihren einsatz danken
meine damen und herren
und trotz der unglaublichen verwüstung
und der großen verzweiflung haben die
menschen vor ort nie aufgegeben in dem
einen jahr seit der flutkatastrophe
wurde schon vieles wieder aufgebaut und
von dieser eindrucksvollen leistung
konnte ich mich selbst ende märz
gemeinsam mit bundeskanzler olaf scholz
vor ort in rheinland-pfalz und den
nordrhein westfalen selbst einen
eindruck gewinnen das war wirklich
beachtlich was dort geleistet wird auch
dafür meinen herzlichen dank an die
menschen vor ort was sie dort geleistet
haben in dem einen jahr ist wirklich
mehr als bemerkenswert meine damen
und die bundesregierung hat für diesen
wiederaufbau zusammen mit den
bundesländern die aufbauhilfe 20 21 mit
einem volumen von 30 milliarden euro
unterstützt dass es wirklich beachtlich
allein die bundesregierung hat 16
milliarden dafür zur verfügung gestellt
ich glaube das war gut und richtig um
den menschen vor ort zu helfen
meine damen und herren wenn eine
katastrophe diesen ausmaßes geschieht
dann wird zu recht die frage gestellt
wie konnte es dazu kommen und was können
wir tun um es künftig besser zu machen
deshalb hat die bundesregierung intensiv
an der aufarbeitung für ursachen der
hochwasserkatastrophe mitgewirkt und
dazu auch im april einen bericht
vorgelegt für die sicherheit aller
menschen in deutschland ist es nun mal
zentral dass wir aus der analyse die
richtigen konsequenzen jetzt auch ziehen
und ich möchte zwei punkte dabei
insbesondere hervorheben wir haben uns
viel zu lange in sicherheit gewogen
durch den klimawandel werden wir in
zukunft aber immer wieder solche
stärkeren naturkatastrophen auch in
deutschland erleben wir hatten gerade
wieder einen schlimmen waldbrand in
brandenburg die furchtbare
flutkatastrophe aus dem letzten jahr und
auch die dichte dieser
großschadensereignisse nehmen leider zu
das zweite ist dass wir uns deshalb auch
viel besser gegen die folgen des
klimawandels und andere krisen wappnen
müssen wir brauchen auf allen ebenen
mehr bewusstsein für die risiken und
gefahren meine damen und herren
leider ist es aber so dass muss ich auch
ganz deutlich sagen dass es beim
bevölkerungsschutz in der vergangenheit
große versäumnisse gegeben hat das haben
wir in den folgen der flutkatastrophe
gesehen wir haben es während der
pandemie
situation gesehen mangelnde bevorratung
und wir sehen es natürlich in besonderer
art und weise seit beginn des
furchtbaren angriffskriegs putin in der
ukraine
für mich ist klar wir brauchen einen
neustart im bevölkerungsschutz denn ein
gut ausgestatteter und leistungsfähiger
bevölkerungsschutz ist entscheidend für
die sicherheit der bürgerinnen und
bürger in unserem land meine damen und
herren
und bei diesem neustart muss der
effizienten schutz der menschen im
mittelpunkt stehen und nicht das betone
ich auch nochmal an der stelle
zuständigkeits debatten das hilft
niemandem weiter wenn die länder wie
gestern hier geschehen auf dem bund
zeigen wenn der bund jetzt wiederum auf
die länder zeigt es sich niemanden die
menschen die bevölkerung will das nicht
wissen und auch nicht hören sagen dass
auch in aller deutlichkeit dafür ist das
thema zu ernst meine damen
wir gehen jetzt viele weitere schritte
und ich hoffe auch gemeinsam da
appelliere ich noch einmal an alle
demokratischen parteien dieses hause
fraktionen dieses hauses um den
bevölkerungsschutz neu aufzustellen wir
müssen intensiv investieren und ich bin
sehr froh und dem finanzminister sehr
dankbar dass wir in den jahren 20 22 und
20 23 über 250 neue stellen in dem
bereich schaffen können und das trotz
einer sehr restriktiven haushaltspolitik
wir schaffen eine verlässliche und
flächendeckende wan infrastruktur und
wir unterstützen das sirenen netze in
deutschland zum wiederaufbau wir sorgen
für moderne warnsystem mit jeder präzise
warnung nach hause bekommt weil das es
so wichtig in diesen
großschadensereignissen und wir brauchen
ein modulares system die zivilschutz
reserve des bundes ist die richtige
antwort auf vielfältige krisen das so
bürokratisch mit labor 5000 umschriebene
hilfesysteme aus containern aus zelten
aus abwasser wasser system aus einer
mobilen hausarztpraxis das ist aber die
richtige antwort auf vielfältige krisen
und deswegen müssen wir dort weiter
investieren und ich bin dem
haushaltsgesetzgeber sehr dankbar dass
wir dafür auch die entsprechenden mittel
zur verfügung gestellt bekommen um
weitere dieser module auch anzuschaffen
ich glaube das ist die richtige
vorbereitung auf vielfältige krisen in
unserem land meine damen und herren wir
können glaube ich sagen ein jahr nach
der krise wir haben daraus gelernt wir
müssen aber noch sehr viel tun um einen
effektiven bevölkerungsschutz zu haben
und auch über die frage des
bevölkerungsschutzes mit den bürgerinnen
und bürgern anders und offener zu
kommunizieren auch das werden wir ändern
meine damen und herren ich bedanke mich
für das 1 in dieser aktuellen stunde zu
so einem wichtigen thema herzlichen dank
für ihre aufmerksamkeit
und für die cdu csu hat das wort detlef
seif
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren die innenministerin hat meine ich
die richtigen worte gefunden was die
helfer angeht aber meiner fraktion ist
es wichtig dass wir es auch nochmal
betonen in der bewältigung der
flutkatastrophe haben ganz ganz viele
ehrenamtliche aber auch hauptberufliche
helfer mitgearbeitet und die haben
unmenschliches geleistet die sind über
ihre belastungsgrenze hinaus gegangen
und sie haben das auch auf gezählt
darunter zählen die angehörigen der
feuerwehren des thw der polizei in der
bundeswehr und natürlich auch einer
hilfsorganisation und ich fand dass ich
fand das auch sehr eindrucksvoll
als abgeordneter das am zweitstärksten
betroffenen wahlkreises wie intensiv die
solidarität war spontan helfer aus nah
und fern landwirte unternehmer die
mussten gar nicht lange darüber
nachdenken die haben ihr schweres gerät
bewegt und sind sofort in den einsatz
gegangen und das meine damen und herren
das sind die wahren helfer dieser
katastrophe und den können wir zutiefst
zu dank verpflichtet sein
auf der anderen seite das hat ministerin
auch schon angedeutet diese
flutkatastrophe wird quasi wie ein
brennglas und macht deutlich wo wir
dringend verbessern müssen beispiel
risiko erkennung der deutsche
wetterdienst das bbk hatten daten
geliefert aber es fehlen strukturen es
fehlte der prozess um diese auch
schnellstmöglich weiterzuleiten und vor
allen dingen für die örtliche ebene zu
interpretieren
im zuge der flutkatastrophe gab es auch
erhebliche schwierigkeiten die
bevölkerung zu warnen und die
angemessenen verhaltens hinweise zu
geben ein radiosender man muss sich das
vorstellen
er hat eine dringende warnmeldung
einfach liegen lassen und hat
stattdessen ein aufgezeichnetes musik
band weiterspielen dass das geht
überhaupt nicht es muss sichergestellt
werden dass die bevölkerung frühzeitig
und flächendeckend gewarnt wird das
sollte auch fester bestandteil der
katastrophenschutz planung der kreise
werden der wieder
der wiederaufbau der sie reden
infrastruktur seit märz 2021 und das
cell broadcast it also warnhinweise
unmittelbar auf das mobilfunkgerät sind
hier genau die richtigen ansätze und es
muss auch sichergestellt werden dass die
bevölkerung die hinweise überhaupt
versteht die warnung reicht nicht ich
muss auch wissen wie habe ich mich zu
verhalten
es gab bürger die das wasser haben
fließen sehen und noch in den keller
gegangen sind um die steckdosen zu
ziehen um gegenstände zurück und die
sind tragischerweise bei dem ganzen ums
leben gekommen ein großes problem war
auch die anforderung disposition der
einsatzkräfte wir hatten diesen großen
bereitstellungsraum 5000 helfer kamen
zusammen im bereich des nürburgrings es
fehlten aber die strukturen um zu
erkennen da stehen spezialisierte kräfte
stattdessen hat man bundesweit nochmals
spezialisierte kräfte angefordert und
die vor ort blieben zunächst mal ohne
einsatz
die durch ausfall der netze strom
mobilfunk aber auch für die
gefahrenabwehr bos teilweise
ausgefallenen funknetze entstandenen
kommunikationslücken wurden leider nicht
immer zügig geschlossen die situation
vor ort konnte deshalb auch nicht
erkundet werden es konnte kein lagebild
ermittelt werden so dass auch die
einsatzkräfte nicht schnellstmöglich vor
ort eingesetzt werden konnten spontan
helfer mit schwerstem gerät sind
teilweise vorort aufgetaucht wurden aber
weggeschickt weil man für sie keine
verwendung hatte weil der damen und
herren da müssen wir dringend
nachbessern es müssen strukturen
geschaffen werden zur koordinierung und
einbindung von spontan helfern vor ort
und besonders wichtig für ein
funktionierendes krisenmanagements sind
krisenstäbe die müssen ihre arbeit aus
dem effeff beherrschen nur hierdurch
lässt sich die chaosphase möglichst
klein halten und dann noch die krise
langfristig in den griff bekommen die
verantwortlichen krisenmanager die
landräte und bürgermeister
müssen dafür bestmöglich ausgebildet
seien und sie sollten im eigenen
interesse die lehrgänge und kurse die
das bbk anbietet dringend nutzen und ich
kann nur empfehlen und ich glaube wir
ziehen da alle an einem strang das bbk
auch im bereich der akademien viel
besser auszurüsten und das deutlich
auszuweiten
es ist
auch so dass krise und krisen management
die abläufe und kommunikationswege
natürlich intensiviert werden müssen
wenn nötig durch schärfere rechtliche
verpflichtungen es ist hier zu begrüßen
dass der neue nrw koalitionsvertrag
vorsieht für krisenstäbe und operative
einheit auf kommunaler und landesebene
katastrophenschutzübungen durchzuführen
ein fortlaufendes lagebild ist für das
krisen-management wichtig auch in fällen
in denen eine katastrophe über mehrere
kreise geht über mehrere bundesländer
muss schnellstmöglich ein gesamt
lagebild vorlegen das im märz 2021
initiierte gemeinsame kompetenzzentrum
bevölkerungsschutz und da ziehen wir
alle an einem strang beim bbk ist die
ein ganz wichtiger schritt
um meine damen und herren wir wissen
alle dass der bevölkerungsschutz und da
sind noch neue aufgaben auf uns
zugekommen diese gesellschaft wird
komplizierter und technischer und
angriffe und schwierigkeiten
katastrophenlagen werden mögliche
häufiger weise auftreten wir wissen ein
sehr komplexes gefüge extremwetterlagen
großbrände pandemien terror lagen cyber
attacken auf kritische infrastrukturen
oder längerfristig stromausfälle darauf
müssen wir uns gemeinsam bund länder und
kommunen bestmöglich vorbereiten wichtig
ist hier aber risiko erkennung
komplettes lagebild einsatz und
verteilung von kräften und vor allen
dingen die professionelle arbeit der
krisenstäbe das ist die basis eines
funktionierenden bevölkerungsexplosion
alle gemeinsam daran aber vielen dank
[Applaus]
war das von der cdu csu die nächste
rednerin kommt jetzt von den
bündnisgrünen hat sich gleich noch mal
beschwert noch ein bisschen redezeit
klappt
am donnerstagmittag
und möchte einfach nur mal darauf
aufmerksam machen dass die tagesordnung
glaube ich bis 2 uhr 30 geht und es wäre
gut wenn sie sich an ihre rede zeiten
halten würden und in diesem sinne
übergebe ich jetzt das wort am nächsten
kam von bündnis 90 die grünen und das
wollte gerade sagen von ungefähr zehn
minuten hatten die spanier in der
vorhergehenden die partie eher ihre
erste bundestags rede gehalten von den
bündnisgrünen und jetzt gleich wieder so
schnell kann's gehen nun also ihre
zweite
[Musik]
an vielen häuserwänden habe ich
handabdrücke gesehen schlamm
handabdrücke große und kleine auf diese
art und weise haben sich viele der über
100000 helferinnen und helfer verewigt
viele davon packen auch heute noch mit
an all diesen menschen kann man nicht
genug danken
ich habe wie viele andere auch die
schrecklichen bilder der flutkatastrophe
gesehen ja eigentlich ganz deutschland
aber so wirklich verstanden was da
eigentlich passiert ist habe ich erste
sich über eine fläche stand um mich
herum steine und geröll schlamm viel
holz und
seltsam in die luft ragenden
metallstangen ich habe eine weile
gebraucht um zu verstehen ich stehe
gerade mitten in einem gleisbett um mich
herum heizöl geruch
man hat an mehrstöckigen häusern durch
wasserflecken absehen können wie weit
gekommen ist ein zwei manchmal drei
stockwerke hoch und häusern auf denen
sich menschen wenn sie glück hatten
haben aufs dach retten können die
menschen im aartal in stolberg oder in
eschweiler haben in sieben stunden
verloren was sich zum teil in sieben in
17 oder in 27 jahren aufgebaut haben die
katastrophe hat viele traumata
hinterlassen dazu kommen ängste
vergessen zu werden und auch ängste dann
mit dem erlebten alleingelassen zu
werden und politisch haben wir viel
angestoßen und trotzdem hört und spürt
man ungeduld
an der stelle bringt es ehrlich gesagt
auch wenig auf gute bewilligungsquote
von hilfsanträge zu verweisen gefühle
haben normal in so einer situation wenig
zu tun mit fanden die betroffenen sehnen
sich nach normalität auch um zu
verarbeiten was es an seelischen wunden
gibt
die trümmerberge sind mit der zeit
kleiner geworden und die brachflächen
fangen an zu blühen aber die großen
herausforderungen sind geblieben wir
stehen noch am anfang des wiederaufbaus
und
an den bahnhof den ich am anfang meiner
rede als solchen nicht erkannt habe
fahren auch heute noch keine züge aber
der nachhaltige wiederaufbau bietet
chancen chancen den ort so neu zu
gestalten die sich dass die menschen vor
ort wünschen es ist unsere aufgabe aus
der vergangenheit zu lernen und es ist
unsere aufgabe
insgesamt resilient dazu werden damit
bei der nächsten überflutung die es
sicher aufgeben wird nicht mehr so viele
helferinnen braucht die dann mit schlamm
händen sich an häuserwänden verewigen
vielen dank
sehr eindringliche schilderung von
miesbach kam der nicht die debattiert
ein jahr nach der flutkatastrophe
vereinigen die zukunft des
bevölkerungsschutzes bislang hat der
bund keine gesetzgebungskompetenz für
den katastrophenfall ohne
verfassungsänderung bleibt das im
bundesamt für bevölkerungsschutz und
katastrophenhilfe bei seinen
koordinierungsaufgaben grundsätzlich auf
eine freiwillige mitwirkung der länder
angewiesen schreibt dazu der
wissenschaftliche dienst des bundestages
der nächste redner kaum von der ard
bernd schattner sich 21 in rheinland
pfalz ums leben kamen hunderte wurden
verletzt tausende verloren hab und gut
viele sind bis heute durch die
ergebnisse traumatisiert für uns als afg
fraktion waren zwei dinge von anfang an
klar wir müssen auf parlamentarischer
ebene alles dafür tun die näheren
umstände dieser katastrophe zu erhellen
und wir werden uns mit voller kraft
dafür einsetzen den betroffenen die
notwendige hilfe zukommen zu lassen
ein jahr nach dem starkregen ereignis
wissen wir durch zahlreiche zeugen und
sachverständigen aus sagen dass viele
tote hätten verhindert werden können
wenn die verantwortlichen stellen ihren
aufgaben nachgekommen werden stattdessen
liegen alle vertreter der
landesregierung schlafen während die
zahl die menschen ertranken nach der
flut nacht taten die ministerpräsidentin
sowie die zuständigen minister dann so
als ob sie nichts gewusst hätten
unverfroren verbreiteten sie die legende
von der unvorbereitete katastrophe ihre
alleinige sorge aber dem image der
landesmutter und ihrer regierung während
die für hochwasserwarnungen zuständige
urlaubs minister im spiegel zum glück
geschichte ist bleibt der für
katastrophenschutz zuständige
innenminister lewentz bis heute weiter
im wald noch immer verbreitet er seine
legende von der lokalen verantwortung
für das tödliche waren fast sagen an der
meine damen und herren nach der ersten
katastrophe folgt nun die zweite auch
nach mehr als einem jahr läuft die
auszahlung der unterstützungs hilfen
mehr als nur schleppend weniger als ein
prozent der mittel wurden bis jetzt
ausgezahlt begründung der regierung man
müsse ja ganz genau prüfen wir welche
mittel erhält sehr geehrte vertreter
dieser regierung diese sorgfalt die sie
hier an den tag legen und ihr eigenen
leute im wahrsten sinne des wortes im
regen stehen lassen diese sorgfalt hätte
ich mir dann doch lieber an einer
anderen stelle gewünscht hier sei nur
der betrug in milliardenhöhe durch nicht
stattgefundene bürger testes genannt am
geld für den wiederaufbau mangel des
indes nicht allein für rheinland pfalz
wurde überwiegend vom bund ein
hilfsfonds in höhe von 18 milliarden
euro zur verfügung gestellt aber dieses
geld kommt bei den betroffenen menschen
überhaupt nicht an so war ende mai aus
der wiederaufbauhilfe lediglich 136,5
millionen euro an privathaushalte für
hausrats und gebäudeschäden ausgezahlt
auch die bisher an betroffene
unternehmen überwiesenen mittel kann man
im verhältnis zum gesamten zum
entstandenen gesamtschaden zumal es
marginal bezeichnen nach einem bericht
des innenausschusses rheinland pfalz vom
siebten juni waren es ganze 31,3
millionen das ist in der summe ebenfalls
weniger als ein prozent des verfügbaren
geldes aber auch den arbeitnehmern tod
am ende des monats ein böses erwachen
die härtefall regelung zum
kurzarbeitergeld muss unbedingt
verlängert werden da ansonsten
zahlreiche menschen in die
arbeitslosigkeit abrutschen werden grund
hierfür ist dass vor allem dass die
betriebe vor ort immer noch nicht wieder
aufgebaut wurden selbst bei der
öffentlichen infrastruktur sieht es
nicht besser aus 4 milliarden euro
bedarf in den landkreisen sondern
festgestellt ausgezahlt waren bis zum 2
juni nur 150,8 millionen
wenn das in diesem tempo weitergeht der
vollständige wiederaufbau der
infrastruktur
hochgerechnet 25 jahre dauern und damit
nur marginal länger wie der bau des
flughafens ber verehrte kollegin lassen
sie mich zum ende meiner rede kommen und
hier vor allem in zahlreichen
freiwilligen helfern und landwirten vor
ort danken ohne deren unverzügliches
eingreifen nach der flut hätten die ein
leser einwohner noch wesentlich länger
schlange gestanden insbesondere die
bauern die an schwerem räumgerät waren
in den ersten tagen und wochen die
helden der region vielen dank für diese
hilfe was ist nicht noch viel mehr opfer
gab ist die mutigen einsatz von
feuerwehrleuten zu verdanken die
besonders am oberlauf der zahllosen
menschen das leben rettete beispielhaft
sei hier die rettungs leistung des
26-jährigen wehrleiters in dem dorf
stand in dem trotz verheerender
materieller zerstörung kein einziger
bewohner sein leben verloren hat und
nicht unerwähnt zum schluss sollte auch
noch die 90 jährige feuerwehrfrau
bleiben wenn ich im einsatz zur rettung
von menschen ihr leben verloren hat
vielen dank
dann schreibt nachdem mit einer klage
die man leider häufig aus den
betroffenen gebieten gehört geld wäre
eigentlich das kommt bei den betroffenen
nicht an nach wie vor sind viele
verwaltungswege zu lang und auch zu
umständlich um sie ordentlich
auszuführen und dann das geld wirklich
zu bekommen sandra butendorfer licht
jetzt sie ist die obfrau im ausschuss
für inneres und heimat der fdp
aus dem buch es war dort nur regen
sondern neumann aus den frühen
morgenstunden des 15 01 20 21 andy
neumann lebt selbst mit seinen beiden
kindern und seiner frau immer toll unser
haus wurde heute nacht im absoluten
watson die flucht sechs befragten im
ersten obergeschoss unseres hauses fest
an unsere autos davon schwimmen und
andere autos geben unser haus kasten das
wasser stieg und stieg bis es nur noch
fünf stufen waren die es vom ersten
obergeschoss getrennt haben was menschen
wie andy neumann und seine familie in
diesen minuten erleben mussten ist für
uns unvorstellbar eine reißende
wassermassen die von jetzt auf gleich
nahezu alles zerstört familie neumann
war es vergönnt dass es sich zumindest
selbst schützen konnten über 180
menschen weil am fall zum nordrhein
westfalen wurde dieses glück im unglück
nicht beschieden sie starten weil sie
der gefahr und das drohende unheil nicht
haben kommen sehen und oftmals erst zu
spät das ausmaß und den ernst der lage
erkennen konnten schuldzuweisungen meine
sehr verehrten kollegen nun kriegen
bringen uns nicht weiter
aber es war einfach sorgen auf
staatlicher ebene
und eines müssen wir im nachgang dieser
katastrophe aber endlich gelernt haben
wir dürfen es nicht mehr verantworten
nicht vorbereitet zu sein
die opfer und geschädigte die bis heute
im aartal und in den weiteren
flutgebieten versuchen in ihrem alltag
wieder normalität zu bekommen müssen uns
diese lehren wir müssen unsere gesamte
ablauf strukturkrise management im
bevölkerungsschutz überarbeiten das
bundesamt für bevölkerungsschutz und
katastrophenhilfe
dass nun endlich gestärkt und ausgebaut
wird muss noch weiter zur zentralstelle
im bevölkerungsschutz entwickelt werden
es musste in kirchlicher hinsicht
koordiniere eine koordinierte
zentralstellen funktion erhalten und
alles über verfügbare kräfte
ressourceneinsatz führung und aufbau
abrufbar haben
sofortige erreichbarkeit
handlungsfähigkeit und umfassende
unterstützung der kräfte vor ort das ist
in meinen augen enorm wichtig
solche extremen
sagen müssen strukturierte geübte und
funktionierende abläufe erfahren
katastrophen wie diese werden uns in
zukunft leider häufiger heimsuchen
auch die gefahr von waldbränden und
wasserknappheit ist dabei ebenso zu
nennen wie die geopolitischen und
militärischen herausforderungen unserer
zeit
den ernste lage den haben wir in
deutschland aber nun endlich begriffen
der bevölkerungsschutz in deutschland
hält endlich den stellenwert den er
verdient aber wir müssen auch noch
stärker den wissenschaftlichen aspekt
und die ressort übergreifende abstimmung
gerade in die lage bilder einfließen
lassen und gemeinsam mit den
innenministern der länder habe das baby
kam vom juni das wichtige gemeinsame
kompetenz zentrum von bund und ländern
gestartet damit ist ein erster schritt
getan um die strukturen und abläufe
zwischen bund und ländern zu verbessern
deswegen muss nun endlich ein
förderalismus dialog angegangen werden
wir auch im koalitionsvertrag vereinbart
ist
diese enormen katastrophen übersteigen
nämlich auf die handlungsfähigkeit der
länder und kreise und beziehen sich
nicht nur auf einen klar abzugrenzen
bereich und hier müssen dem und mehr
unterstützungsmöglichkeiten gegeben
werden und dabei geht es nicht darum
jemanden etwas wegzunehmen oder ihm
seinen kompetenzen zu beschneiden
sondern darum jahrhundert katastrophen
mit allen verfügbaren ressourcen und
kräften koordiniert und das stichwort
ist wirklich koordiniert zu bewältigen
sind sie im haushalt 20 22 tätigen
investitionen der fortschritts koalition
richtig und wichtig und bilden einen
guten startschuss auf dem weiter
aufgebaut werden muss der weg der führt
in die richtige richtung
und muss in den nächsten jahren weiter
konsequent beschritten und gestärkt
werden wir müssen den bevölkerungsschutz
neu denken und das sind wir den opfern
und geschädigten wieder familie von andy
neumann besonders aber den vielen toten
der jahrhundert flut katastrophe ihr
leben lassen mussten schuldig herzlichen
dank
der deutsche landkreistag hat sich genau
gegen die
verlagerung richtung bund gewendet die
landkreise kennen die lage vor ort so
dass die argumentation die
verantwortlichkeit gehört dorthin wo die
katastrophe ist und nicht weit weg vom
ort des geschehens
dennis trainer andré hahn von den
ländern mit mindestens 100
86 todesopfern und milliardenschäden
hier in deutschland war ohne zweifel ein
extrem verheerendes naturereignis allen
opfern und deren angehörigen spreche ich
auch im namen meiner fraktion die linke
unser aufrichtiges mitgefühl aus und ich
möchte mich auch das waren andere schon
getan bedanken bei den einsatzkräften
von thw feuerwehren der bundeswehr dem
roten kreuz und anderen
hilfsorganisationen so viel vielen
freiwilligen die sich vor ort in den
betroffenen regionen engagiert haben
ihnen haben wir viel zu verdanken und
das will ich an dieser stelle auch
ausdrücklich sagen
neben
neben der frage wie die betroffenen
menschen aber auch unternehmen beim
wiederaufbau unterstützen müssen wir als
parlament vor allem antworten geben was
wir tun können damit sich solche
schadensereignisse möglichst nicht
wiederholen auch wenn wir alle wissen
dass es eine absolute sicherheit nicht
geben kann
albrecht broemme der ehemalige präsident
des technischen hilfswerks hat in der
anhörung des innenausschusses unter
anderem zwei sehr bemerkenswerte sätze
gesagt mit blick auf die medial immer
wiederkehrende formulierung es habe sich
im aartal um eine jahrhundertflut
gehandelt erklärte er zitat ich müsste
eigentlich schon 800 jahre alt sein so
viele jahrhundert fluten habe ich schon
erlebt zitat ende ich finde diese
aussage sollte uns doch zu denken geben
das wort von der jahrhundertflut fiel
beispielsweise auch beim extrem
hochwasser an der elbe im sommer 2002
ich wurde selbst im elbtal war damals
mitglied des sächsischen landtages und
natürlich stellt sich die frage ob
damals die richtigen lehren daraus
gezogen wurden wenn man sich den von der
sächsischen staatsregierung in auftrag
gegebenen untersuchung abhängigen
untersuchungsbericht ansieht dann hat
man ein erschreckendes déjà vu ich habe
leider nicht die redezeit um das im
einzelnen auszuführen aber die probleme
waren und sind 20 jahre später leider
nahezu identisch unzureichende
warnsysteme für die bevölkerung massive
störungen der krisenkommunikation
zwischen kreis- land- und bundesebene
der ausfall des telefonnetzes nicht
vorhandenen notstromaggregate und so
weiter aus den krisen lernen dieses
gestern im cdu csu antrag das bedeutet
aus unserer sicht nicht nur die
katastrophe immer teil nicht zu
vergessen sondern auch nicht die 16
jahre unionsgeführte regierung und des
zuständigen innenministeriums das
federführend für den spa waren beim
bevölkerungsschutz verantwortlich waren
es kann und es kann und darf nicht sein
das uns helfer aus dem
katastrophenschutz in der anhörung des
innenausschusses
sagen müssen dass ihre fahrzeuge er ins
museum gehören als für einen
hilfseinsatz noch taugen und es ist doch
eine farce das wären bundesweit viel zu
spät sirenen ausgetauscht werden und
endlich erneuert werden aber nicht
einmal einheitlich geregelt ist welche
art von sirenen eingebaut werden und auf
welche warnten die bevölkerung
wie reagieren sollen und ein jahr nach
der flut kämpfen die betroffenen teils
weiterhin um den wiederaufbau der häuser
und mit versicherungen was viel zu
schleppend vorangeht das dürfen wir
nicht einfach hinnehmen
und ich sage auch
das zerstörte häuser oftmals am selben
gerade überfluteten standort neu
errichtet werden ist genauso
problematisch wieder umstand dass es
immer noch keine
elementarschadenversicherung gibt die
ich schon vor zwei jahrzehnten im
landtag gefordert habe ich habe eingangs
von zwei bemerkenswerten setzen des thw
präsidenten räume gesprochen die er in
der jüngsten anhörung im innenausschuss
gesagt hat der zweite satz lautete zitat
wenn im nächsten jahr wieder so ein
schweres hochwasser käme würde alles
leider genauso passieren wie im urteil
ich hoffe wir sind uns alle einig dass
das nicht sein darf und deshalb muss man
endlich den zivilen katastrophenschutz
nachhaltig stärken und wenn die
bundesregierung das nun endlich
loszulegen letzte bemerkung frau
präsidentin wenn die bundesregierung das
nun ernsthaft angehen will dann werden
wir das gerne unterstützen herzlichen
dank
sagt andré hahn der übungs aus stricher
für zivilen katastrophenschutz seiner
fraktion
der nächste redner in dieser debatte ist
der krise der zuständige
stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der spd geben
musste
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren das
hochwasser im aartal in der eifel in
großen teilen von nordrhein-westfalen in
städten wie stolberg erftstadt
hagen-hohenlimburg sondern im sauerland
dem portal aber auch in den
bundesländern bayern und sachsen war
eine auch heute noch kaum fassbare
katastrophe für die menschen vor ort und
eine tragödie mit leid trauer zerstörung
für die betroffenen gebiete städte
gemeinden viele dörfer mit über 180
todesopfer und hunderten von verletzten
der verwüstung ganzer landstriche und
schäden in milliarden höhe war es eine
der größten naturkatastrophen der
deutschen nachkriegsgeschichte die
hilfsbereitschaft
bundesinnenministeriums ifx etr hat es
angesprochen sie war von anfang an
überwältigen die hauptamtlichen und
ehrenamtlichen helfer der feuerwehr und
des thw verschiedener bundesbehörden der
bundeswehr der hilfsorganisation der
krankenhäuser arztpraxis und
pflegedienste sie haben enormes
geleistet und auch zahllose private
helfer landwirte handwerker aus allen
gegenden des landes haben angepackt und
gemeinsam mit den betroffenen die keller
die wohnungen und die häuser von schlamm
befreit und das thw hat heute eine
kampagne gestartet und sie haben auch
die kampagne zwei sätze geschrieben die
sehr gut passen danke für den mut danke
für den zusammenhalt in allen gebührt
unser großer dank und sie leisten noch
heute übrigens an vielen wochenenden
freiwillig hilfe und unterstützung vor
ort und da kann man nur danke sagen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen unsere
aufgabe ist es vor dem hintergrund ein
jahr später die richtigen lehren zu
ziehen denn man muss es klar sagen es
wurden fehler gemacht auch auf
politischer ebene diese müssen wir
benennen und aufarbeiten und
entsprechende untersuchungsausschüsse
auch in mainz in düsseldorf sind
eingesetzt beziehungsweise werden
richtigerweise fortgeführt der umgang
mit der katastrophe und auch die
koordinierung der hilfsaktivitäten in
meinem heimatbundesland nordrhein
westfalen hat im nachhinein auch viele
politische fehleinschätzungen offenbart
anstatt den menschen schnell konkret und
effektiv zu helfen kam die reaktion
oftmals zu spät kein gemeinsames
vorgehen es wurde oft unabgestimmt
agiert wurde sehr oft reagiert nicht
agiert und ich glaube das eint uns das
darf nicht wieder passieren
auf der anderen seite zeigt das
hochwasser auf das hochwasser auch
schonungslos die defizite auf die noch
immer im katastrophen- und
bevölkerungsschutz vorhanden sind die
mangelhafte koordination der
verschiedenen ebenen das unzureichende
funktionierende erlangt hätte ein
fehlendes flächendeckendes warnsystem
für die bevölkerung ja diese baustellen
müssen wir gemeinsam zügig angehen und
das ist unsere aufgabe hier auch
entsprechend die weichenstellungen auf
vorzunehmen ich will aber auch sagen
dass bei den auszahlungen der
aufbauhilfen auch viel passiert ist aber
langjährige antragsverfahren auch
zermürbende auseinandersetzungen auch
gerade mit versicherungen sorgen für
wenig verständnis bei den betroffenen
und hier müssen wir ansetzen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen unser
ziel muss es sein dass der staat in der
krise auf allen ebenen handlungsfähig
ist und die sicherheit für die menschen
überall in deutschland garantiert wenn
es darauf ankommt nur ein starker
bevölkerungsschutz kann das garantieren
und daher müssen wir alle gemeinsam
nachbessern kommunen länder und auch der
bund ohne wenn und aber und ich bin
bundesinnenministerium nennt sie feser
sehr dankbar dass sie hier grad und auch
ihrer rede keine zweifel hat aufkommen
lassen und wir hier eine enge
kooperation mit allen ebenen gemeinsam
als ampelkoalition auch voranbringen
wollen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
mit der einrichtung des gemeinsamen
kompetenzzentrums beim bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz und katastrophenhilfe
in bonn haben wir richtige
weichenstellungen und erste schritte
bereits auf den weg gebracht das bbk und
das technische hilfswerk benötigen
jedoch auch weitere und stützungen damit
sie in ihren originären aufgaben
gestärkt werden und es ist glaube ich
gut und richtig dass das bbk an der
spitze fachlich kompetent mit der
nötigen erfahrung jetzt aufgestellt ist
denn die bürgerinnen und bürger das will
ich deutlich sagen sie haben einen
anspruch darauf dass der staat ihre
leben schützt dass wir die richtige
ausrüstung für diejenigen zur verfügung
stellen die helfen das kostet geld aber
es ist gut angelegtes geld für die
sicherheit der bürgerinnen und bürger in
unserem land dafür haben wir auch hier
in berlin die verantwortung vielen dank
für ihre aufmerksamkeit
vielen dank und jetzt spricht für die
unionsfraktion mächten treiben meine
damen herren sie sehen das kleine
fenster erneut bei uns eingeblendet wir
warten nach wie vor auf eine
stellungnahme von boris johnson die
tatsächlich jetzt bald kommen soll wir
werden dann dem bundestag dafür
verlassen einstweilen aber bleiben wir
bei dieser wichtigen debatte über ein
jahr nach der flutkatastrophe mit
mechthild heil pardon von der cdu/csu
dimensionen dieser katastrophe tote
verletzte
wunden an leib und seele
viele viele traumatisierte ein
vollkommen zerstörte stahel ein
verlorenes zu hause wir sagen ein
verlorenes paradies
ziemlich schnell setzte sich dann jedoch
ein anderes gefühl durch hoffnung und
dankbarkeit
gestützt war das auf den zusammenhalt in
den dörfern und in den nachbarschaften
weil die dörfer und meistens wirklich
von der außenwelt abgeschnitten waren
war man darauf angewiesen und gestützt
auch auf die unglaubliche hilfe die von
außen kam aus ganz deutschland und weit
darüber hinaus und gestützt auf die
überwältigende spendenbereitschaft die
bis heute anhält
hoffnung aber auch gestützt doch das
versprechen der politik hier in berlin
und auch in mainz wir werden alles für
euch tun was wir können wir werden
zeigen dass ihr schnellen wiederaufbau
in deutschland umsetzen die damalige
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel hat gesagt
da muss keiner angst haben der
wiederaufbau wird nicht am geld
scheitern
geld steht
in ausreichender menge zur verfügung
versprechen gehalten der damalige
finanzminister und jetzige bundeskanzler
oder stolz den kann ich mit den worten
zitieren das was man mit geld in ordnung
bringen kann das werden wir mit geld in
ordnung bringen heute ein jahr nach der
katastrophe ist das vorherrschende
gefühl zwischen dorsel der ober- und
sind sich wo die einen rhein fließt
enttäuschung
enttäuschung gegenüber den
verwaltungsapparat 'nen hier im bund und
auch in den ländern weil das geld eben
nicht bei den betroffenen vor ort
ankommt bei den privatleuten und bei den
unternehmen bei den kommunen und noch
nicht mal zeitnah aber auch nicht am
ende überhaupt nicht ankommt und nicht
in ausreichender höhe und enttäuschung
weil der neuaufbau viel viel viel zu
langsam geht das geld kommt nicht an
weil die ampel in rheinland pfalz im
regelfall nur bereit ist 20 prozent
abschlag auf den schaden auszuzahlen
nordrhein westfalen hat 40 prozent
prozent aus
bis diese erste zahlung dann bei den
betroffenen ankommt auf dem konto liegt
müssen die betroffenen nicht nur den
antrag stellen sondern monat für monat
vorziehen vorfinanziert nicht nur die
erste zahlen sondern jede weitere
zahlung muss der betroffene
vorfinanzieren und dass derjenige der
nichts hat dem das haus weggeschwommen
ist in mitmenschen oder angehörige
verstorben sind das geld kommt nicht an
weil die antragsverfahren zu aufwendig
zu kompliziert sind viele flutopfer
haben bis heute noch keinen tag gestellt
obwohl sie sicherlich ohne zweifel dazu
berechtigt wären da helfen auch nicht
die info points im tal und es helfen
auch nicht die jetzt im tal aufsuchende
tür zu tür beratung das ist ein guter
ansatz da will ich gar nicht darüber
meckern aber die antragsstellung die ist
so kompliziert sie muss digital erfolgen
wie ist so kompliziert das ist wirklich
einfach wochen dauert und nochmal monate
dauerte dann nachher das verfahren
wirklich so ein abschluss und einen
erfolgreichen abschluss bekommen ist
deshalb die bundesregierung aber auch
liebe landesregierung schmecken sie
endlich diese verfahren ab erhöhen sie
die zahl der leute die diese verfahren
bearbeiten bei der esd und sorgen sie
endlich für immer den gleichen
ansprechpartner
muss vieles vor ort trifft dann auch im
keim erstickt immer mit dem gleichen
hinweis
wenn in ein paar jahren der rechnungshof
dann kommt dann kann es sein dass er da
einspruch erhebt oder es heißt in der
verwaltungsvorschrift in der frau gibt
es dazu keine klare aussage also nein
wir machen das nicht und wenn die
landesregierung dann den rheinland pfalz
bewegungen versagt dann häufig mit dem
hinweis da stellt sich der bund quer ich
vermisse den aufschrei hier aus dieser
ampel denn widerspruch nach rheinland
pfalz dass wir uns im wunsch querstellen
oder muss ich davon ausgehen dass sie
tatsächlich recht haben wir waren felser
und es an uns hier im bund an ihnen
liegt dass ich in aathal nichts bewegt
eins ist klar so gelingt der aufbau
nicht nach einem jahr hat dann ist er
nicht gelungen und das wird in den
nächsten jahrzehnten zu nicht gelingen
deswegen mein appell setzen sie sich mit
den ampeln in rheinland-pfalz oder auch
in ihr im bund endlich mit den
rechnungshöfen zusammen und klären sie
was förderfähig ist und was nicht und
setzen sie sich zwischen bund und land
endlich zusammen und passen sie die vv
an wir sind ein jahr nach der flut
wissen doch heute besser was da drin
stehen muss man kann es bitte tun sie
das und leser ja sie haben gesagt sie
haben recht damit kein schwarzes peter
spielt dann hören sie doch mit auf und
kommen endlich ins handel 37 sie doch
nicht den schwarzen peter da noch immer
aufs land und das land wieder zurück zu
sie zu ihnen und bitte bitte schaffen
sie auch klarheit darüber welche
personalkosten jetzt endlich für den
wiederaufbau in den kommunen bezahlt
werden bis jetzt ist das nicht klar es
wirkt denn personal eingestellt weil es
eben nicht getragen vom bund ein
unhaltbarer zustand die menschen und die
kommunen vor ort können sich das nicht
leisten
sorgen sie für praxistaugliche
regelungen bei der abgrenzung der kosten
wieder aufbau oder zum beispiel
hochwasserschutz und verlängern sie
endlich das kurzarbeitergeld sie haben
das gerade wieder abgelegt die leute
haben keine arbeit da sie haben das
unternehmen ist weggeschlossen und sie
nehmen ihnen noch den letzten rest an
unterstützung weg verlängern sie mit
einer sonderregel das kurzarbeitergeld
in den flutgebieten herr scholz vorteil
ist hilden klar zum abschluss es fehlt
eine schnelle unbürokratische hilfe ist
fairer zusammenarbeit ist die einführung
bei ihnen packen sie die probleme an
enttäuschen sie die betroffenen nicht
noch einmal
[Applaus]
als nächstes erhält das wort leon ihr
gehabt für bündnis 90 die grünen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kollegen liebe kolleginnen liebe
bürgerinnen und bürger wenn wir heute
zurückblicken auf das hochwasser das
sich vom 14 auf den 15 juli letzten
jahres durch flussläufe und täler
geweißt hat dann ist die dimension immer
noch schwer zu fassen meine gedanken
sind bei denen die angehörige freunde
verwandte verloren haben das engagement
und der einsatz der vielen nachbarn
freunde völlig fremder der einsatzkräfte
der hilfsorganisation der feuerwehr und
das thw das sind die lichtblicke in
dieser katastrophe gewesen sie haben
über tage wochen und monate vor ort zur
bewältigung der lage beigetragen da
danke dafür
wir sehen den betroffenen und den
helferinnen schuldig unsere lehren aus
der katastrophe zu ziehen und umzusetzen
zwei zentrale anliegen möchte ich stark
machen dort können wir und dort müssen
wir handeln erster punkt koordination
ich habe mit einer vielzahl von
einsatzkräften gesprochen und sie
beschreiben wir den bürger durch
unterschiedliche standards und
benennungen in den einzelnen
bundesländern im ersten moment weiß kaum
jemand außerhalb bayerns was der
wasserrettungszug der bayerischen
wasserwacht leisten kann er war im
einsatz und dementsprechend wurde
eingesetzt nämlich im großen teil gar
nicht die schwierigkeit der
verständigung zeigt sich leicht an einem
kleinen beispiel fährt der thüringische
rüstwagen mit dem funkrufnamen florian
dornburg camberg 71 1 nach einer falls
zum helfen dann steht die 71 im
funkverkehr für ein mehrzweckfahrzeug
keiner weiß was das ist fährt er weiter
nach nrw ist es die 71 auf einmal ein
feuerwehrkran
die funk kennung verliert einen teil
ihrer funktion und bremst damit aus und
diese beispiele es ist ja nur ein
kleines in denen unterschiedliche
sprachen zwischen den bundesländern
existieren
es gibt sie zuhauf sie bremsen und
machen den einsatz langsamer wertvolle
zeit die menschenleben kosten können
dass die cops gemeinsam kompetenzzentrum
bietet jetzt die möglichkeit dass bund
und länder dieses problem des wirrwarrs
lösen mit vereinbarungen zum gemeinsamen
vorgehen und einer lagebild übersicht
sollte die freiwilligkeit hier scheitern
müssen wir uns hier im parlament
gedanken machen wann wir diesen zustand
im sinne der sicherheit der bürgerinnen
nicht mehr dulden können und selbst
bundesweit ministern als einführen
zweiter punkt warnung unser waltz ist
löchrig das zeigt die katastrophe das
zeigt der wahltag in bayern cell
broadcast in kommt noch waren apps sind
viel zu wenig verbreitet sie reden
lückenhaft vorhanden oft nicht
ansteuerbar für den alarm das ist eine
situation in der sich kein akteur wieder
kommune noch land noch der bund aus und
auch gerade deswegen braucht das jetzt
jeden schwung um mehr abdeckung zu
erreichen um jeden zu erreichen ich sage
ja wir als bund müssen das serien
förderprogramm weiter für cell broadcast
in kommt und ich würde so weit gehen
dass wir die nina vanessa auf jedem
handy betriebssystem vor installieren
lassen aber die länder müssen eigene
sirenen förderprogramme komplementär
einrichten die kommunen müssen sich
jetzt vor ort spezifischer waren
konzepte anlegen hier nur auf den bund
zu warten ist wie das wort warten schon
sagt zu langsam
lassen sie uns
voran gehen ein fazit noch nie war die
einzig zu groß dass veränderung
bevölkerungsschutz notwendig sind wie
zurzeit wir arbeiten dran wir wollen
umsetzen helfen sie mit diese probleme
zu lösen
und es folgt steffen ja nicht für die
afg fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren am nachmittag des 12
juli 20 21 war alles noch ruhig in der
folge viele niederschläge bis zu 450
liter wasser pro quadratmeter
die kommenden wassermassen töteten noch
mehr menschen als die hochwasser an der
oder in den jahren 1997 und 2010 fast
190 menschen starben allein in rheinland
pfalz wurden etwa 500 gebäude völlig
zerstört etwa 200.000 menschen waren
ohne strom vom mobilfunknetze brachen
völlig zusammen hunderte kilometer
straßen und über 100 brücken wurden
massiv beschädigt es gibt nichts was
einen geliebten menschen der von uns
gegangen ist zurückholen kann doch es
gab neben all dem tod der zerstörung und
dem menschlichen leid auch so etwas wie
einen funken hoffnung und diese funken
hoffnung waren die tausenden vor allen
ehrenamtlichen helfer die über tage und
wochen ihre persönlichen grenzen und
darüber ihre persönlichen grenzen gingen
und weit hinaus bis an die grenzen des
machbaren
hinarbeiteten diesen menschen gilt unser
dank
ein baggerfahrer vor an einem haus heran
welches von dem wasser eingeschlossen
waren und wie ist eine g unfähige frau
durch das fenster in seine schaufel
klettern und brachte sie in sicherheit
einsatzkräfte des technischen
hilfswerkes retteten ein baby und seine
eltern die sich auf einem überfluteten
feld auf einen hochsitz befanden diesen
tausenden helfern gebührt unser tiefster
dank
[Applaus]
es ist eine kernaufgabe von uns
politikern alles in unserer macht
stehende zu tun um künftig besser auf
der erde katastrophen vorbereitet zu
sein die sachverständigen im
innenausschuss haben uns hierzu
wertvolle hinweise gegeben die
zuständigkeiten im katastrophenfall sind
zu bündeln zerstöre kommunikationswege
müssen schneller wiederhergestellt
werden neue serien zur warnung der
bevölkerung gehören flächendeckend
bereitgestellt führungskräfte von
katastrophenschutz organisationen müssen
trägerübergreifend gemeinsam ausgebildet
werden und ganz wichtig es sind einsatz
stäbe für katastrophenfälle im
alarmsystem zu schaffen welche innerhalb
einer stunde einsatz und innerhalb von
zwei stunden handlungsfähig sind und
wenn sie mir sagen wollen das ginge
nicht sage ich unsere kameraden von der
feuerwehr sind innerhalb von zwölf
minuten am einsatzort es muss also gehen
katastrophenschutz ist nicht die zeit
für parteien politik wir werden unseren
beitrag leisten um einen reformprogramm
noch in dieser wahlperiode mit
aufzustellen meine fraktion wird hier
konstruktiv mitarbeiten vielen dank
[Applaus]
für die fdp fraktion folgt jetzt der
kollege manuel höferlin
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren vor einem jahr wurde in
deutschland wurde deutschland die
menschen in deutschland von einer flut
getroffen vor allen dingen die
bundesländer nordrhein-westfalen
rheinland-pfalz mein zuhause wurden
stark getroffen und es ist mehr paris
beschrieben worden ganze straßenzüge
ganze häuser sind zerstört worden
betroffen haben alles verloren wo in den
wohnzimmern noch die couch stand war
plötzlich nichts und ich brauch das buch
von andy neumann gelesen in dem er
beschreibt wie das wasser höher und
höher stieg wir können uns das nicht
vorstellen wenn man nicht dort war und
den höchsten preis haben die menschen
gezahlt die dort ihr leben gelassen
haben über 180 sind immer noch menschen
vermisst und nicht nur denen auch den
angehörigen den menschen die heute noch
unter den folgen leiden sind wir
schuldig zwei fragen zu stellen die
erste wie konnte das passieren um
aufzuarbeiten was schief gelaufen ist
und deswegen gibt es auch
untersuchungsausschüsse in den ländern
und es ist wichtig dass man daraus die
richtigen schlüsse zieht aber viel
stärker ist die frage doch zu stellen
was können wir heute auf den weg bringen
dass so etwas nicht wieder passieren
kann meine damen und herren und wenn man
zurückblickt und schaut wie dort die
einsätze geschehen sind und wer dort
geholfen hat dann kann man einer gruppe
von menschen nämlich den vielen
ehrenamtlichen ich würde es auch nochmal
sagen alle hilfsorganisationen aber auch
jedem einzelnen menschen ich kenne so
viele menschen die sich einfach auf den
weg gemacht haben dorthin die einfach
hingefahren sind mit irgendeinem gerät
mit einem unimog mit einem großen lkw
mit was auch immer denen will ich noch
mal danke an denen lag es nämlich nicht
dass es zu wenig hilfe gab und deswegen
mein herzliches danke an alle die
menschen
was aber ein problem waren war das die
struktur darum versagt hat viele dieser
menschen sind frustriert wieder
zurückgekommen ohne geholfen zu haben
weil sie nicht wussten wo sie und
niemand ihnen sagen konnte wo sie
eingeteilt werden können und das ist das
problem das vorwiegend ist sein
strukturelles versagen der organisation
von katastrophenhilfe die sich in diesem
konkreten fall manifestiert hat wir
haben auch schon in einem anderen
beitrag gehört wenn in den
bereitstellung setzen dann heraus dass
sie haben es gesagt 5000 menschen stehen
er seit ich weiß ja satz gesagt dann
kann man da nicht mehr koordinieren wer
wann wohin geht man weiß gar nicht mehr
welche einsatz fähigkeiten in einem
solchen bereitstellungs platz liegen und
das muss dringend strukturiert werden
mal da und herren und das zweite hat der
kollege eckhard gesagt eine katastrophe
ist es wenn in der katastrophe die
helfer nicht die gleiche sprache
sprechen und das beginnt bei den punkt
identifikationen der einzelnen kräfte es
geht aber auch über die allgemeine
führungs sprache hinaus und das liegt
daran dass es kommt es zum letzten punkt
diejenigen die die kleinen katastrophen
vor ort gut managen können bei größeren
lagen einfach an ihre fähigkeiten
grenzen gestoßen sind und andy neumann
hat es am montag in der anhörung
betitelt mit dem überschrift katastrophe
ist kreisliga das ist provokativ es
trifft es aber auf den punkt weil wenn
wir das nicht anders organisieren können
dann werden wir nicht dazu kommen dass
es hilft wenn bundesweit menschen zu
einem ereignis strömen um zu helfen wenn
wir dort keine organisation haben und
eine abgestufte resilienz haben dass man
vorher weiß wer eigentlich zuwachs in
der lage ist zu helfen dass es eine
stelle gibt zb das bbk das angerufen
werden kann und wo man sagt ich brauche
ein hubschrauber mit seilwinden und man
weiß die gibt es in bayern aber nicht in
rheinland pfalz wenn man das nicht weiß
wo rufe ich an dass jemand kommt erlebt
wer wäre das nicht organisiert krieg und
das ist die aufgabe dann sind bei der
nächsten katastrophe aufgeschmissen und
das ist nicht in erster linie eine frage
des geldes sondern es ist in besonderer
weise zuerst eine frage der struktur
deswegen bin ich froh ministerin feser
dankbar dass ihr es angeht mit den
ländern und mit den kommunen mit den
kreisen zu sprechen dass wir gemeinsam
besser koordinieren und dann dort wo es
nötig ist mit entsprechend finanziellen
mitteln aufstocken und dafür sorgen dass
so etwas nicht wieder passieren kann
herzlich
es folgt der fraktionslose abgeordnete
matthias helferich
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren schlagen wir mal
gemeinsam den aktuellen
verfassungsschutzbericht auf dort heißt
es über ihren neuen fantasie phänomen
bereich den verfassungsschutz relevante
delegitimierung des staates als beispiel
hierfür kann das vorgehen in erscheinung
getretener person im zusammenhang mit
der hochwasserkatastrophe in nrw und
rheinland-pfalz genannt werden über ein
reines hilfsangebot hinaus wurde
versucht die angespannte
versorgungssituation vor ort im sinne
einer delegitimierung staatlicher
strukturen zu instrumentalisieren doch
die die wirklich unsere demokratie und
staat orten verächtlich machen war nicht
deutsche die deutschen halten es war
eine cdu-umweltministerin heinen esser
die sich auf mallorca sollte wird ihr
volk im schlamm vor den trümmern der
eigenen existenz stand es war eine grüne
umweltministerin spiegel die sich in den
frankreich von den strapazen ihrer
eigenen corona politik erholte es war
ein wdr der trotz milliarden budgets
nicht das volk wandte sondern lieber die
lange ard pop nacht spielte sie alle
haben versagt und unserer staatlichkeit
dadurch schweren schaden zugefügt sie
alle hatten nicht den anstand wortlos
und demütig für ihre
verantwortungslosigkeit zurückzutreten
und nun wagen sie als solidarischen
deutschen die sich nicht nur als helfer
mit weißen sneakern wie helge rind
inszenierten ihre schlapphüte auf den
hals hetzen sie sollten sich wirklich
schämen und bis heute übernehmen sie
keine verantwortung
opfer der flut diebe in nrw wurden 24
städte von mehr als 140 plünderern
heimgesucht entschädigung erhalten die
opfer der flut liebe nicht und warum
nicht weil sich beim 90 prozent der
tatverdächtigen handelte es sich um
ausländer und migranten klar ohne und
andere migrantische langfinger aus 24
nationen nahmen den opfern der
flutkatastrophe ihr letztes hab und gut
und wenn die bevölkerung zukünftig
schützen wollen dann schützen sie vor
migrantischen glaubenden und der
spätrömischen dekadenz
verantwortungsloser ministerin vielen
dank
[Applaus]
herr abgeordneter ist werden wir die
rede gleich nochmal anschauen und
behalten wir zumindest ein ordnungsruf
wird erteile ich das wort für die spd
lena werner
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen sehr geehrte damen
und herren am 14 juli letzten jahres war
ich auf dem heimweg von einem
wahlkampftermin als mich bilder von
meinen nachbardörfern erreicht haben in
denen sturzbecher durch die straßen
liefen ich habe bilder bekommen aus
meiner stadt die unter wasser stand und
das war noch nie so das hat mich sehr
schockiert ich konnte das gar nicht
richtig einordnen und verstehen was da
gerade passiert
aber liebe menschen aus dem ahrtal und
im aartal meine erinnerungen sind im
vergleich zu dem was sie vor einem jahr
erlebt haben nichts
nächste woche jährt sich die gewölbte
gewaltige flutkatastrophe die in ihrer
heimat in weiten teilen von
rheinland-pfalz und nordrhein-westfalen
schwere verwüstungen und fürchterliches
schicksal
verursacht hat sie haben ihr zuhause
verloren ihre existenzen und im
schlimmsten fall auch freunde oder
familie
das war die schlimmste naturkatastrophe
die unser bundesland je erlebt habe ja
vielen dank ans werner fittkau der
deutsche bundestag debattiert hier immer
noch in einer debatte über die lehrerin
ein jahr nach der flutkatastrophe am 15
juli 2021 unter anderem starben ja
135 menschen und die frage ist wie man
das in zukunft besser verhindert wie man
besser vorher waren kann die zukunft des
bevölkerungsschutzes steht hier im
mittelpunkt der debatte und lena werner
hat schon seit ungefähr 23 minuten das
wort von der spd
entlang der ahr sieht man immer noch die
zerstörung man sieht berger an stellen
wo vorher einmal häuser gestanden haben
die menschen im ort halten trotzdem
positiv in die zukunft sie bauen neu auf
es finden wieder veranstaltungen und
weinfeste stadt tages und
wochenendausflüge sind möglich und gerne
werde ich deswegen an dieser stelle
dafür ins zu gehen und dort einen urlaub
zu verbringen
der tourismus ist die größte
wirtschaftskraft im aartal nach den so
schwierigen zeiten in der pandemie
wurden unternehmen einzelhandel und die
tourismusbranche mehrfach hart getroffen
und kämpfen ums finanzielle überleben
ein beispiel ist ein hotelier aus bad
neuenahr ahrweiler seine situation und
seine erfahrungen sind exemplarisch für
die vielen betroffenen betriebe vor ort
auch sein hotel wurde durch die flut
schwer beschädigt der wiederaufbau läuft
jedoch wird der betrieb nicht vor
nächstem jahr aufgenommen werden können
dazu kommen sorgen um das halten und neu
anwerben von den mitarbeitenden denn
auch die infrastruktur funktioniert aber
vieles ist immer noch provisorisch und
die region ist immer noch in einem
andauernden ausnahmezustand sowohl die
bundesregierung als auch die
landesregierung in rheinland pfalz haben
sich eingesetzt und schnell
unterstützung auf den weg gebracht und
den menschen vor ort zu helfen und ich
würde hier kurz klarstellen wollen dass
die abschlagszahlungen in rheinland
pfalz für härtefälle seit gestern
bekannt gegeben auf 40 prozent erhöht
wurden wichtig ist dass bund und länder
immer herr einstand gehen deshalb ist es
sehr zu begrüßen dass diese regierung
zusammen mit den ländern ein
schutzsystem für notlagen entwickeln
wird ein großer dank geht an die
ehrenamtlichen kräfte der feuerwehren
thw drk malteser die bundeswehr und
viele weitere denen der flut nacht und
darüber hinaus im einsatz waren mit
wachsender anzahl aber auch intensität
von naturkatastrophen auch bei uns in
deutschland dürfen wir beim
katastrophenschutz den
bevölkerungsschutz und der entwicklung
und verbesserung von frühwarnsystemen
nicht nachlässig werden denn die
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnisse zeigen
extremwetterereignisse werden in zukunft
wahrscheinlicher wir werden sie nicht
verhindern können und es ist unsere
aufgabe dafür zu sorgen dass niemand
mehr in deutschland sehr deutschland
derart von einer flut oder anderen
naturkatastrophen überrascht wird und
genau das tun wir
für die cdu csu fraktion spricht jetzt
die abgeordnete mechthilde wittmann
[Applaus]
der präsidentin frau bundesministerin
herr bundesminister
ich pflege im regelfall die
debattenbeiträge dieser seite des hauses
einfach zu ignorieren
aber das was sie vorher gehört habe
erschüttert mich und ich schäme mich
dass ein mitglied dieses hauses in
diesen stunden solche worte angesichts
der bekannt
ich möchte mich ausdrücklich bedanken
dass zweiten teil der debatten sogar
drei kabinettsmitglieder anwesen jetzt
wieder entschuldigen sie will endlich
hat hier wieder kommen noch nicht
gesehen ich glaube das wird einfach der
sache gerecht es wird den menschen im
alltag gerecht zu sehen dass wir sie
nicht nur nicht vergessen haben sondern
dass wir uns die zeit und zwar nicht
irgendwann in der nacht sondern mitten
am tag für sie nehmen neben all den
maßnahmen die getroffen werden seitens
des bundes und auch seitens der länder
und ich glaube das ist gut so und es ist
ein gutes zeichen ins tal hinein
meine damen und herren die katastrophe
die sich im juli vergangenen jahres
abgespielt hat die mich genauso
fassungslos immer noch erschüttert lässt
wie sie alle mit einigen wenigen
anscheinend die haben wir eine besondere
wetterlage zu verdanken die haben wir
einen besonderen
topographie zu verdanken aber sie war
auch nicht ganz neues gab ein ganz
ähnlich gestalter des hochwassers
mehrfach bereits im aartal und an er
genau genauso katastrophal im jahre 1804
juli 1804 der unterschied ist der
unterschied ist heute haben wir mehr
wasser in der atmosphäre durch eine
klimaerwärmung die wir auch alle
festgestellt haben und heute haben wir
mehr versiegelung der böden und deswegen
ist es ganz ganz wichtig und ganz
angemessen dass wir uns darüber
unterhalten
im nachgang dazu wie wir lehren daraus
ziehen können und diese notfalls auch
durchziehen müssen lassen sie mich eine
kurze anleihen nehmen an dass alle
hochwasser 1999 aus meiner heimat
ähnliche topographie alt lagen wo wir
aus den hochalpen starke schmelzwasser
haben zu mit blockierten tiefdruck lagen
so dass es zum entsprechenden abregnen
kann die maßnahmen die ergriffen wurden
waren so effizient dass wir seither
außer kleinen nur an abgängen nur wenig
probleme dort haben wir haben hochwasser
verbauungen dort initiiert es gibt keine
überbauungen überschwemmungsgebieten es
gibt entsprechende rückhaltebecken und
genau dieses muss die politik überall
durchziehen und nicht nur da wo wir dank
einer nicht vorhandenen koalition zu
diesen zeiten einfach reagieren und
handeln konnten dieses handeln ist jetzt
gefragt und meine damen und herren für
mich wäre ganz ganz wichtig dass wir
dieses gemeinsam tun feser und sie haben
bereits die stützungsmaßnahmen des
bundes erwähnt im übrigen noch von der
alten regierung aber da waren sie mit
ihrer partei dabei die amis betrifft sie
zwar manchmal aber ich will sie ihn
ausdrücklich hiermit anerkennen mit
dabei waren und mir ist ganz ganz
wichtig dass wir hier nicht und das
haben sie leider getan von versäumnissen
im bevölkerungsschutz sprechen meine
damen und herren in den letzten jahren
wurde beispielsweise beim thw der
haushalt verdoppelt und die unsere
regierung unter an und dieses ist auch
gut so und so machen sie auf weiter und
wir waren uns beim haushalt des
innenministeriums ganz weitgehend einig
dass wir auf dem weg weiter gehen dass
wir weiter erneuern können und wenn wir
von versäumnissen wirklich versäumnissen
bevölkerungsschutz in den letzten jahren
jetzt hören dann finde ich das nicht
angemessen dieser lage aber dann muss
ich halt auch mal welche ansprechen der
staatssekretär der für bevölkerungs und
katastrophenschutz
zuständig ist im innenministerium ist
seit einem halben jahr unbesetzt wir
würden ihn aber dringend brauchen zum
einen um den weg weiterzugehen im
übrigen wäre auch für migration
zuständig auch dazu haben wir
ausreichend zu tun und meine damen und
herren wenn wir von versäumnissen
ausgehen da muss ich ihnen halt auch
sagen so und so vieles findet in den
ländern statt das bayerische beispiel
habe ich ihnen gebracht
in rheinland pfalz reagiert seit 1991
roth abwechselnd mit grün und gelb also
in summe eine ampel und einige
prominente namen darf ich ihnen dazu
kennen sie heißen einen namen erspare
ich ihnen da habe ich einfach ein
bisschen mitleid sondern aber sie heißen
auch wissing und lemke und dann zeigen
sie nicht auf die mit dem finger
woanders sind sie sind dort seit langem
genug da beide gehen zu können und sie
sollten dieses dann auch entsprechend
tool und umsetzen anstatt mit dem finger
auf andere zu zeigen und wenn sie sagen
es gab versäumnisse
dann sage ich ihnen das bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz und katastrophenhilfe
wurde erstmals von der spd abgeschafft
und musste wieder neu aufgebaut werden
und der bauantrag hat uns gezeigt dass
die führung dort ebenfalls ein spd
kollege einfach nicht gut waren und
deswegen macht es eben keinen sinn zu
geben ich bedauere zutiefst
dass sich unserem zehn-punkte-plan von
gestern nicht zugestimmt haben es war
eben angemessen einen vorzulegen oder
war auch inhaltlich gut denn wir haben
genau das was sie alle mengen
vorgeschlagen nämlich unter anderem eine
zivile reserve mit einer grundausbildung
die werde bevölkerung zur verfügung
stellen mit einer entsprechenden
vernetzung der jeweiligen katastrophe
und hilfsdienste aber zum beispiel auch
mit einer aufnahme eines registers so
könnten sich zum beispiel ehrenamtliche
registrieren lassen in welchem umfeld
können sie mit welcher befähigung und
mit welchem gerät gegebenenfalls
kurzfristig helfen wenn wir das haben
und dann weiß jeder der nicht weiß dass
es jetzt gerade schon eigentlich
notwendig wo kann ich den abrufen die
einen zins für suppe kochen und die
anderen sind für das schwere gerät das
er zum beispiel eine maßnahme wie haben
sie gestern erwähnt und ich möchte genau
wie sie allen ehrenamtlichen danken aber
allen auch den jährigen die sich auch in
den städten und gemeinden den
verwaltungsbeamten etc dabei die wir die
arbeitszeit hinaus einsetzen lassen sie
uns denen dieses vergelten so wie wir
das in vielen anderen schauen können das
ehrenamt gehört weiter unterstützt und
ich glaube das machen wir gemeinsam
vielen dank
mechthilde wittmann war das aus der
unionsfraktion in der debatte des
bundestages über konsequenzen aus der
flutkatastrophe im aatal vor einem jahr
und in dieser debatte wird der nächste
redner sein harald ebner aus der
fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen und
außerdem ist er vorsitzender im
ausschuss für umwelt naturschutz und
kollegen vor ziemlich genau sechs jahren
habe ich hier in diesem pult zur
flutkatastrophe in braunsbach bei
schwäbisch hall in meinem wahlkreis
gesprochen die bilder damals waren
erschreckend und viele hätten nicht
gedacht dass nur fünf jahre später das
alles beispiellos und um derart
vielfaches übertroffen werden könnte wie
es vor einem jahr im aartal geschehen
ist das leider betroffenen und
angehörigen der todesopfer ist
unermesslich
heute müssen wir nicht nur dem leid und
den milliarden schweren schäden ins auge
schauen sondern auch der tatsache dass
wahrscheinlichkeit und häufigkeit
solcher extremwetter ereignisse zu
nehmen und dann zur katastrophe werden
wenn sie wie im aartal auf geografische
besonderheiten wasser gesättigt die
böden und unmittelbare bebauung in
flussnähe treffen es ist gut dass wir
heute den katastrophenschutz auf den
prüfstand stellen und stärken
prognosemodelle katastrophenmanagement
und hilfe sind unerlässlich aber wir
dürfen nicht weiter uns davor drücken
von einer ehrlichen analyse
wir müssen uns auch die frage stellen
wie sorgen wir künftig nicht nur für
katastrophen für den katastrophenfall
vor sondern wie entschärfen wir bereits
deren entstehung mehr klimaschutz mehr
erneuerbare energien sind dazu zwingend
und das haben wir vorhin endlich
beschlossen und auf den weg gebracht
dafür ganz herzlichen dank
aber wir müssen auch klimaanpassung
jetzt umsetzen wie muss landnutzung
unter veränderten klimabedingungen
aussehen wir müssen böden vegetation und
wälder beschaffen sein um möglichst viel
wasser möglichst lange speichern zu
können die wissenschaftlichen
empfehlungen liegen auf dem tisch mehr
raum für flüsse durch angepasste land
nutzungen schaffung von
überschwemmungsflächen hochwasser und
klima residenz bauen mehr grün und blau
als grau in der stadt eine schwamm stadt
die folgen der klimakrise durch
wasserspeicherung abmildern kann eine
win-win-situation für klimaschutz und
klima
vorsorgewerte kolleginnen und kollegen
wasser ist quelle allen lebens auf
diesem wunderbaren planeten aber oft
auch ursache verleiht unermessliches
leid weil es oft entweder zu wenig oder
zu viel davon gibt und wir müssen beides
in den blick nehmen beides wird
verschärft durch die klimakrise das
heißt zusätzlich zu den
klimaschutzbemühungen brauchen wir neben
einer klima anpassungsstrategie für
dieses land auch eine nationale
wasserstrategie und zwar um zwei fliegen
mit einer klappe zu schlagen sowohl
wassermangel als auch wasser überschuss
auf der anderen seite mit den gleichen
maßnahmen zu entschärfen darf zu müssen
wir endlich aufhören gegen biologische
prozesse zu arbeiten die sich in
abermillionen jahren an den umgang mit
wasser angepasst haben warum nutzen wir
nicht dass endlich das biologische
potenzial wasser zu speichern und
langsam wieder abzugeben lassen sich nur
in beton und stahl denken den wir
selbstverständlich auch brauchen wo es
nicht anders geht aber das darf nicht
unsere alleinige antwort sein wenn wir
es nicht schaffen in böden vegetation
und landschaften die biologischen
potenziale zur wasseraufnahme zu nutzen
bauen wir uns zu tode ohne am ende
erfolgreich zu sein
dafür haben wir den natürlichen
klimaschutz auf den weg gebracht der zb
mit der renaturierung von mooren und
gewässers systemen hier den richtigen
weg einschlägt deshalb kolleginnen und
kollegen sind die vier milliarden euro
die die bundesregierung für den
natürlichen klimaschutz zur verfügung
stellt gut investiertes geld wir müssen
all diese dinge
und all diese dinge jetzt anpacken wir
dürfen die menschen in diesen regionen
nicht vergessen und wir müssen den
wiederaufbau intensiv begleiten dabei
müssen wir aber die gefahr immer
mitdenken in die gefahr hinein zu bauen
ist schlicht nicht vernünftig und zum
vorsorgenden katastrophenschutz gehört
zwingend auch die katastrophen
vorbeugung und die muss klima
anpassungsstrategien in landbau
landnutzung landschaftsgestaltung
städtebau und wasserhaushalt umfassend
mit einbeziehen nur dann kommen wir
unserer verantwortung für die menschen
in diesem land wirklich nach vielen dank
parada vorsitzender im ausschuss für
umwelt und naturschutz in der debatte zu
konsequenzen aus der flutkatastrophe im
aatal und anderswo vor knapp einem jahr
nächster redner hier sebastian hartmann
der innenpolitische sprecher der spd
fraktion
und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen liebe mitbürgerinnen und
mitbürger vor allen dingen auch aus den
vielen betroffenen landkreisen und
städten in den vielen ländern die die
hochwasserkatastrophe am 14 am 15 juli
des vergangenen jahres noch in den
knochen haben die diese debatte
verfolgen jeder von uns kann den tag
einordnen was er oder sie getan hat
kolleginnen und kollegen haben dies
gemacht und es sind eindrückliche
schilderungen gewesen und ich war am 14
juli im rahmen meiner aufgaben als
damals zuständiger berichterstatter für
den zivil- und katastrophenschutz bei
der bundesleitung des bbk beim
technischen hilfswerk in bonn ich werde
nie den regen vergessen der da auf uns
nieder prasselt und jeder und jeder von
uns der in der region lebt und ich lebe
im rhein sieg kreis im nachbarkreis zum
rhein erft kreis harz angesprochen aber
der direkten nachbarschaft zwar niemand
von uns wird vergessen dass das eine
außergewöhnliche lage war und wir waren
mit dieser lage konfrontiert und wir
ahnten im verlaufe des tages das ist
eine außergewöhnliche lage und meine
damen und herren wir haben uns als
parlament hier verständigt gemeinsam auf
eine vereinbarte debatte weil es nicht
gelingen kann jetzt die einzelne
verantwortung style in einem föderalen
staat auf die eine seite zu schieben und
sich selber aus der verantwortung
herausziehen und in weiten teilen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ist es gelungen
doch was bringt es an einzelnen stellen
die auszahlung programme eines einzelnen
landes zu kritisieren und ich glaube es
gehört auch zur guten ordnung halber
dazu zu begrüßen dass das land rheinland
pfalz dauerhaft in der debatte vertreten
ich hätte auch die bundesratsbank an der
stelle gesehen denn es ist eine
gemeinsame
deswegen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
verzichte ich darauf auf einzelne punkte
die meinem heimatland nordrhein
westfalen nicht gelungen sind oder nicht
so gut waren wie man sich das als
opposition und das ist die
sozialdemokratie nordrhein-westfalen
gedacht es wäre zu einfach und zu billig
über einzelne kabinetts abwesenheiten zu
sprechen oder nicht ausgezahlte geld
weil es kein mensch in diesem land etwas
bringt und etwas voran bringt wenn wir
an uns selbst aus der verantwortung
heraus nehmen und das ist etwas was uns
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen über alle
föderalen ebenen gemeinsam bewegen muss
weil was bringt der appell immer wieder
zu sagen beim nächsten mal machen das
anders beim nächsten mal mache ich es
besser und tun es dann doch wieder nicht
in diesem föderalen staat und es wird
auch alleine nicht daran liegen und
gelingen können immer nur über das zu
sprechen was nicht gelungen ist weil in
einer krise und einer katastrophe muss
man sich auch an das halten was uns
stark gemacht hat und zusammengehalten
und deswegen liebe mitbürger und
mitbürger die helferinnen und helfer
sind
niemand ist damit getan und geholfen
wenn wir in der krise uns
auseinanderdividieren und auseinander
treibt dieses unverantwortliche hetzer
und spalter hier auch heute wieder
versucht
weil in der krise halten wir zusammen
und haben uns unter und lassen sie uns
doch aus dieser debatte eines vermuteten
die katastrophe darf nicht zum
normalfall werden aber wir müssen damit
leben dass in unserer durch
technologisierten welt in unserem engen
miteinander
katastrophen stattfinden können die
digitalisierung und die technik werden
uns davor nicht bewahren und nicht
retten aber es darf kein negativer
gewöhnungseffekt entstehen weil wir
wissen es wird ein jahrzehnt an der aa
wieder aufgebaut und wir müssen auch im
jahr zwei und im jahr drei und im jahr
vier danach hinschauen und jedem
einzelnen der opfer der vielen
helferinnen und helfer die in
verantwortung auch verletzt worden sind
oder ums leben gekommen sind wir es
schuldig ist besser und anders zu machen
ihre kolleginnen und kollegen und
deswegen muss man eine zweite gewöhnung
an der katastrophe auch vermeiden wir
brauchen eine gemeinsame verabredungen
was die finanzmittel angeht das ist der
standard an einem parlament aber es ist
auch die gemeinsame verabschiedung dass
wir uns besser vorbereiten es ist etwas
zum klima gesagt worden mit der
katastrophe neben lernen bedeutet aber
auch sie nicht hinzu und dort müssen wir
bessere vorsorge machen und es kann auch
nicht sein dass wir wenige tage vor dem
hochwasser dem 14 und 15
übereinstimmend der auffassung waren gut
dass der bahn tag abgesagt worden ist
und genau das ist 2021 passieren wir
müssen waren wir müssen sensibilisieren
können wir müssen jede und jeder unserer
mitbürgerin in die lage versetzen auch
sich damit auseinanderzusetzen in einem
demokratischen rechtsstaat es vorsorge
uns alle angeht das ist etwas was ich
als lehre aus diesem jahr der
katastrophe mitnehmen aus dieser debatte
und ich finde über weite teile haben
viele teile der demokratischen
fraktionen das getan und das ist ein
guter punkt aufzusetzen wir haben im
innenausschuss dazu eine sehr
beeindruckende anhörung anfang dieser
woche so massen kollegen und herzlichen
dank liebe kolleginnen und kollegen auch
für die möglichkeit hier sprechen zu
dürfen als jemand der in einem das
schwerst betroffene kreise dank
sebastian hartmann innenpolitischer
sprecher der spd fraktion am ende
nochmal mit persönlichen anmerkungen
zwischendrin hat der vergleichsweise
subtile die landesregierung nrw
kritisiert bzw deren management in auch
nordrhein westfalen war von massiven
hochwassern getroffen im
vergangenen juli aber nicht so schlimm
oder mit abstand nicht so schlimm wie
das ahrtal in rheinland-pfalz aber womit
er auf jeden fall recht hat dass die
länder damit in der verantwortung waren
und womit er auch recht hat dass die
länderbank bei dieser debatte
so gut wie nicht besetzt gewesen ist